all civilized countries should be
standing firmly by Israel's side yet
president macron and some other Western
leaders are now calling for an arms
embargo against
Israel shame on
them just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran
why because they did not have it on
their mobile devices or their gadgets
brothers and sisters imagine you have a
app the Quran app which not only shows
you how much rewards you get but reminds
you to read the Quran gives you
reminders download the Quran app now and
let it testify for you on that you read
it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends before I go into the video
inshallah we are here every Sunday and
Friday at the da table inshallah please
guys whatever you can donate it will
help our da table to continue we're
trying to raise funds for 9 months so we
can carry on giving our da let's get
straight into the video Benjamin
Netanyahu the Satan of this our time the
of our time has now lost his mind and he
so much so he is now threatening macron
I mean out of everybody in that life
Subhan Allah can you imagine it's like
Abu jahal threatening Abu laab yes and
Subhan Allah brother and sisters we're
going to watch the video now of his
dismay his his he's so upset and
saddened that Subhan Allah that they
have decided to put an embargo and try
to stop the missiles or these weapons
that they are selling to them now it's
very interesting because I want to know
why would macron of anyone for that
matter say such a thing we don't know
but what we know is Benjamin n after the
statement he bombed one of the petrol
stations that is owned by the French
government but alhamdulillah let's watch
the video for ourselves and come back
m
today Israel is defending itself on
seven fronts against the enemies of
civilization we're fighting in Gaza
against Hamas those Savages who murdered
raped beheaded and burned our people on
October 7th were fighting in Lebanon
against kisala the most heavily armed
Terror organization in the world which
was planning an even greater Massacre
than October 7th on our northern border
and that has rocketed Israeli towns and
cities for nearly a year we're fighting
against the houis in Yemen and the
Shiite militias in Iraq and Syria that
together have launched hundreds of
drones and missile attacks against
Israel we're fighting against terrorists
in Judean Samaria who are trying to
murder civilians in the heart of our
cities and we're fighting against Iran
which last week fired over 200 ballistic
missiles directly at Israel and which
stands behind the seven front war
against
Israel I have a message for FS the
forces of barbarism led by Iran
all civilized countries should be
standing firmly by Israel's side yet
president macron and some other Western
leaders are now calling for an arms
embargo against
Israel shame on them is Iran imposing an
arms embargo onala on the htis on Hamas
and on its other proxies of course not
the access of Terror stands together but
countries who supposedly opposes Terror
axis call for an arms embargo on Israel
what a
disgrace well let me tell you this
Israel will win with or without their
support but their shame will continue
long after the war is won for in
defending ourselves against this
barbarism Israel is defending
civilizations against those who seek to
impose a Dark Age of fanaticism on all
of us rest assured Israel will fight
until the battle is f the forces of
barbarism led by Iran
so guys you saw that for yourself subh
Allah you you heard what maon had said I
mean after to everyone you wouldn't
expect maon to come and say that but at
least you know it shows you know there's
maybe some kind of hope for him but this
Satan has come Subhan Allah and is
shocked he is shocked why because he
thinks because this the reason why we
cannot put everybody in these categories
and of course there's political gains
and God knows for that reason but
alhamdulillah majority of so much of
non-muslims around the world have been
speaking up of Palestine that is why it
is such an important reminder for us
brothers and sisters that we should not
look at individuals in Islam and
whatever it is our religion doesn't
teach that we look at this Believers the
same they're not they are not the same
Allah even tells in the Quran when it
comes to Christians yes they are not the
same so for us it's very important to
understand that there are good
individuals there are Muslim non-muslims
who are on the rooftops of Elbert
systems literally protesting putting
glue on their hands how many Muslims do
that how many of us go and do what
they're doing so it shows there is
goodness in them we ask Allah subhana
tal to guide them to Islam but Subhan
Allah brother and sisters may Allah
subhana wa tala carrying exposing Israel
and I believe their end is coming and a
time will come where the Christians and
the Muslims and the Jews will live under
that B Banner of Palestine once again
again inah and surprisingly for you all
as well to see macron telling the the
Western World to stop arming Israel is a
big shock to the system and to me I was
like no way but it is a reality and
that's the reason why Benjamin Netanyahu
the corrupt vile F individual of our
time may Allah subhana destroy him in
this life and Hereafter is losing his
mind the whole world is now seeing the
reality of Israel with their own eyes
they are losing the battle in uh when it
comes to social media people's
perception universities all around the
world they are losing the battle against
Hamas hisbah Iran they are losing the
battled on all grounds and they have
10,000 Israeli soldiers have been either
killed or wounded or disabled may Allah
subhana T increase them in this misery
inshallah and humiliate them and give an
end and inshallah our brothers and
sisters will be liberated may Allah subh
bless you guys